truth is the beginning of every good to
the gods and of every good to
man the greatest wealth is to live
content with
little an empty vessel makes the loudest
sound so they that have the least wit
are the greatest
babblers
false words are not only evil in
themselves they infect the soul with
evil no one is more hated than he who
speaks the
truth books give a soul to the universe
Wings to the Mind flight to the
imagination and Life to
everything well and poverty one is the
parent of luxury and ulence the other of
meanness and viciousness and both of
discontent the right question is usually
more important than the right
answer for a man to conquer himself is
the first and noblest of all
victories you can discover more about a
person in an hour of play than in a year
of
conversation the eyes are more exact
Witnesses than the
ears if you do not take an interest in
the Affairs of your government then you
are doomed to live under the rule of
fools wise men speak because they have
something to say fools speak because
they have to say
something beauty lies in the eyes of the
beholder reality is created by the mind
we can change our reality by changing
our
mind a good decision is based on
knowledge not
numbers the beginning is the most
important part of the
work if a man neglects education he
walks lame to the end of his
[Music]
life good people do not need laws to
tell them to act responsibly while bad
people will find a way around the
laws knowledge without Justice ought to
be called cunning rather rather than
wisdom opinion is the medium between
knowledge and
[Music]
ignorance false words are not only evil
in themselves but they infect the soul
with
evil people are like dirt they can
either nourish you and help you grow as
a person or they can stunt your growth
and make you wilt and
die those who tell the stories rule
society when men speak ill of thee live
so as nobody May believe
them courage is knowing what not to
fear education is teaching our children
to desire the right things
character is simply habit long
continued a house that has a library in
it has a
soul good actions give strength to us
and Inspire good actions in
others writing is the geometry of the
Soul
to find fault is easy to do better may
be
difficult no wealth can ever make a bad
man at peace with
himself love is the name for our pursuit
of wholeness for our desire to be
complete the price of apathy toward
public affairs is to be ruled by evil
men
[Music]
lack of activity destroys the good
condition of every human
being the heaviest penalty for declining
to rule is to be ruled by someone
inferior to
yourself I am the wisest man alive for I
know one thing and that is that I know
nothing
the measure of a man is what he does
with
power ignorance the root and stem of
every
evil be kind for everyone you meet is
fighting a harder
battle human behavior flows from three
main sources desire emotion and
knowledge
we are twice armed if we fight with
faith there are two things a person
should never be angry at what they can
help and what they
[Music]
cannot poetry is nearer to vital truth
than
history the direction in which education
starts a man will determine his
future he who commits Injustice is ever
made more wretched than he who suffers
it know how to listen and you will
profit even from those who talk
badly he whom love touches does not walk
in in
darkness life must be lived as
play everything that deceives may be
said to
enchant attention to health is Life's
greatest
hindrance it is impossible to improve
the world if first the man does not
improve
our Envy always lasts longer than the
happiness of those we
Envy virtue is the desire of things
honorable and the power of attaining
them there is in every one of us even
those who seem to be most moderate a
type of Desire that is terrible wild and
Lawless
no more excellent nor more valuable than
Wine was ever granted mankind by
God music and Rhythm find their way into
the secret places of the
soul the wise man will want to ever be
with him who is better than
himself you take the words in the sense
which is most damaging to the
argument any man May easily do harm but
not every man can do
good those who don't know must learn
from those who
do he who wishes to serve his country
must have not only the power to think
but the will to act
the evil never attains to any real
friendship either with good or
evil twice and Thrice over as they say
it is good to repeat and review what is
good wonder is the feeling of the
philosopher and philosophy begins in
Wonder better little well done than a
great deal imperfectly
done we do not learn what we call
learning is only a process of
recollection knowledge becomes evil if
the aim be not
virtuous the excessive increase of
anything causes a reaction in the
opposite
direction
he who steals little steals with the
same wish as he who steals much but with
less
power the mind is not a vessel to be
filled but a fire to be
[Music]
kindled thank you for watching which
quote did you like best
let us know in the
comments